what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I am running on like three hours
of sleep right now so you guys are gonna
have to bear with me
I am totally exhausted but this is the
conclusion of Batman the white knight
and whole week how does Shawn Murphy's
pulling out all the stops and I love
this here's the cool thing about DC
rebirth and these these Batman esque or
these mini-series that are going on
these are many series that like they
could build off of you can make
universes out of each one of these mini
series and that's what's so cool about
this is it gives us this really cool
story and then it makes us want more
right I mean up to this point it was
basically that like Jack Napier somehow
got his hands on a set of pills that he
could take and the Joker personality
would recede and it would allow the Jack
Napier personality to arise and it was
the first time that we'd seen that so
you basically had like this sane
rational human being that initially
seemed to be turning the city of Gotham
on Batman which was true to a degree but
then it was more along the lines of
let's fix the city of Gotham because
Batman's not doing it now ultimately
things went awry
the original Harley Quinn who basically
left she was replaced by the new Harley
Quinn and then when Jack Napier went
sane he went back to the original Harley
Quinn and the new Harley Quinn started
calling herself neo Joker and then
activated this giant freeze cannon that
basically froze Gotham City and that's
where we're at at the moment and when
you get into this whole thing is
basically Joker and Batman have to team
up to take on neo Joker because that was
the ultimatum
you'll tomato was if you want me to fix
things send me the Joker give me Joker
back and this it's kind of holding the
city of Gotham and ransom and it puts
Batman in a very precarious situation
because on one hand who knows what neo
Joker will do to the actual Joker maybe
she's so obsessed with him she'll kill
him you know
the whole play misty for me kind of
situation or it could be that like
she'll do the two of them will run off
and they'll start committing more crimes
in Gotham and things will be worse than
they were before
you know Neo Joker rose to prominence
before all this happened it creates like
a very very tough situation it's so
ultimately this is kind of like the
Gotham basically like the goth of an
anti terror group the police working
alongside the rest of the bat family
essentially working to track down neo
Joker now I remember in the the last
couple story arts the last couple issues
what Shaun Murphy established is that
neo Joker had seized control of the
entire Gotham villain community and so
they're under her control and they're
doing exactly we would expect they're
really more like standing in the way
than anything else they're again kind of
serving their purpose really playing
more security than anything else but
what it does is it basically allow
Batman and Joker to essentially
penetrate a penetrate through the
defenses of the forces of poison ivy and
then like show up or neo Joker his and
that's what evened up having like actual
Joker show up to neo Joker and that's
the cool thing that's what I love so
much about this it's almost kind of like
this in comic book idea that there's two
versions of the Joker there's the Joker
we think we know and then there's the
actual Joker and that's really where
we're neo Joker is at the moment right I
mean you have this chick and she's like
oh I love the Joker I love the idea of
what he does he's so fun and you know I
always loved hanging out with him
because he made me feel like I was alive
you know and then there is the Joker as
he really is and it's almost like this
idea that like he's been pulling punches
all this time because when he shows up
he immediately attacks neo Joker her
idea was it like the Joker would return
and the two of them would be in love and
they would run off hand in Hamm the
Joker would love her and all those
things that's not true at all the Joker
wants to take her out now of course
following this you wouldn't have
basically having the technology of the
Mad Hatter which is destroyed by the
Joker himself and that means I like the
control over all the villains by neo
Joker is essentially released but what
this does is it leads Clayface into
essentially attacking the Joker now this
is kind of a cool thing we only get this
for a couple panels right like we only
get this for maybe you know three panels
four panels or what have you
it's not the biggest thing in the world
but it is cool it really is indicative
of like the danger that Clayface poses
they don't stay and say oh man we got a
defeat Clayface no they run because in
this situation Clayface would destroy
them now the other half of this is that
with Harley you know that the original
Harley and Jack Napier jumping into the
gym into the Batmobile Jack maybe has
been able to seize control the Joker
persona has been pushed back and is kind
of like this this dedication to Harley
Quinn what it really does here is the e
basically sits down and says you were
the only one in Gotham City that ever
really believed that I existed nobody
believed that there was a good side to
the Joker and so it's a way for Jack
Napier to basically say look like I
fallen in love with you all over again
and it's this amazing experience because
from there like you end up having like
neo Joker who shows up you know kind of
racing alongside them because Clayface
damaged the Batmobile and neo Joker says
there's room for one more on this thing
and Jack Napier is coming with me and
the funny thing is that Jackson initial
response is no Harley Quinn needs to
live and so what is it happening is
Jackie basically says look only one of
us is gonna make this out of this we're
crashing where we were we're coming up
on a wall only one of us is gonna make
it out he hits the button he ejects
Harley Quinn and Jack Napier smashes
into the wall
and the Batmobile explodes and I saw
this and I was just like holy cow no way
it was I was just like wow did it
because like you you never really see
that like you read the whole thing about
about you know Batman the White Knight
and it's like well of course Jackie
Napier's gonna make it to the end like
of course Jack Napier is gonna so act no
way he's gonna die here and then you
look at this whole thing and it's like
Jesus I mean the explosion basically
starts wreaking havoc within the that
cave itself you end up having leaks all
these different things that go on now of
course because Victor fries had come
along with the bat family in an effort
to basically reverse-engineer this giant
freeze cannon that his father made of
course it does work I couldn't really
see the story in me with Gotham City you
know Gotham City just being frozen over
forever but then what we also end up
figuring out finding out here it's a
Jack Napier basically survived that that
man brings it like he jumps into the
water brings him back to the surface and
Jack Napier makes it enough from there
it switches over to the fight between
Harley Quinn and neo Joker and this is
not a fight that's based out of any real
perspective of like the direction Gotham
City should go in it's a core between
two women who believe they've lost a man
they love and his and it's interesting
because it's a fight over love but the
cool thing about this is remember Neo
Joker is the new kid on the block she
didn't have all that experience she
hasn't been around all this time but
when you're talking about classic Harley
Quinn she's not someone to snuff at she
can be really really dangerous and so
her lashing out initially she goes to
kill like neo Joker but then suddenly
you know you basically have Duke Thomas
who jumps on her an ear in her ear piece
and says Jack Napier is alive you're
fine like do not kill that chick because
if that happened then classic Harley
Quinn would cross the line she can't
come back from something else at all I
want you guys to also notice too is that
the various villains are being carted
away in a Gotham City police vehicle
this is the same kind of vehicle you saw
from Batman the Animated Series question
for you guys it has nothing to do with
this story which show do you think was
better Batman the Animated Series were
eczema in the animated series I'm biased
I'm saying x-men but I'm curious to see
which one you guys come up with but
nonetheless you know with this whole
thing the agreement was that if Jack
Napier I guess you know was if he was
essentially kind of allowed to go free
or at least you know working alongside
Batman then he would have a full
confession he would confess to
everything that he did when he was Jack
Napier when he was working behind the
scenes when he was manipulating things
that was the whole point he had to make
a confession which he does but this is
kind of a beautiful moment because
they're essentially like assured off you
know like Jack Napier's assured off to
his prison cell which is really more of
like a nicer version the one that I
think previously belonged to Harley
when she used to study him as the Joker
and what happens is he basically tells
like like Batman and Commissioner Gordon
you have to marry us like if like I'd
want to marry Harley Quinn but I want to
marry her as Jack Napier I don't want to
have to marry her as the Joker and the
issue is that the Joker keeps trying to
push himself back out he keeps trying to
make his appearance no and so you end up
having a priest it kind of shows up and
he just runs through all the wedding at
wedding announcements you know like hey
Jack Napier do you take all acquitted
marry you and he's like I do it's like
Harley Quinn do you promise to do all
the stuff that I just said to Jack
Napier and she's like I do and then
before Jack Niebuhr can say like I do
The Joker personality pops up and it's
like I do this it's not a great big huge
moment this feeds into the part of the
story where Shaun Murphy built up the
idea that Joker was legitimately in love
with Harley Quinn and that with the
Joker persona and the jack neighbour
persona fighting over the same body The
Joker won out because his love for
Harley Quinn was just that much more
extreme but it is kind of interesting
and it is kind of funny here and so what
we end up doing is picking up in the
aftermath of this whole white knight
event and the sense that you basically
have Jack navier's confession
essentially saying hey look when I
became sane I realized that Gotham City
would never trust me so I basically set
up circumstances I used criminals I set
them loose so everybody would look there
and then I infiltrated the mayor's
office and then in turn stole
information about the Batman devastation
fun I burned down my library so you guys
think the the the villains had come
after me too I orchestrated all these
things to basically take away your
perspective from Munn at the same time
you have you have like Duke Thomas he's
being interviewed by the press and the
cool thing here is that Duke Thomas
stands by his perspective write it like
he stands by his beliefs the press kind
of you know pushes him and asked him and
says hey look do you regret the fact
that you teamed up with Jack Napier and
his answer is Jack maybe or screwed up
like yeah he did some stupid things he
wasn't a hundred percent honest but if
you were 100 percent honest like like
I'd be curious to see what we could find
out about you so at the end of the day
his whole stance is the only thing that
really matters to me is that when it
came down to it no one would come to
backport nobody would come to this
neighborhood and try to find a way to
make it better
Jack Napier showed up here and he showed
up here without any protection knowing
he might die and his message was I want
to make backport a better place and I
want to extend this improve in a back
port to Gotham City overall and so the
result here is that Duke Thomas
basically says I would do it all over
again despite the mistakes that he made
it's why the mistakes of Jack Napier
made at the
in the Gotham City Police Department
acknowledges the fact that they
basically ignored a quarter but they
never send cops there that if there was
a crime in back port it was back towards
problem but now that everything has sort
of been put under a microscope that
everybody is looking into all these
different things the Gotham City Police
Department is correcting it and so it's
really a way to kind of find this
peaceful resolution to a part of the
city that really was in a lot of ways a
complete and total war zone and so what
we end up getting is this amazing
revelation we have Harley Quinn who's
sort of just on a bridge and I guess
enjoying the night or what have you and
Batman shows up and what Batman says is
that the pills that made Jack may be
your same didn't come from nowhere
Harley Quinn was the one behind it the
whole time she's the one that made the
pills that made him st. and the whole
reason why was because she knew that
Jack Napier was there that there was an
actual good side to the Joker all that
needed to happen was that it needed to
be brought out and so she orchestrated
it at all
she fed the pills as she she gave the
pills to the Joker knowing that he would
take them eventually because the Jack
Napier persona as weak as it was at the
time would find a way to make it happen
she knew the Joker which heiser that
Batman would chase after the Joker she
knew the Batman was dangerous did he had
a reckless disregard for life in Gotham
City or at least that's how people would
see it and so what she ended up doing
was following the two of them so that
when that conflict at the beginning of
the story happened and Batman and Joker
got into a fight and Batman beat the
crap out of the Joker then she recorded
the whole thing and she released it to
the Internet she set all this in motion
and it was like wow it was one of the
coolest reveals and and what we end up
learning is it like Jack Napier figured
that out a long time ago and each hold
Batman what was going on but Batman
always stayed hands-off because Jack
Napier asked him to but when the
question is asked why did you do this
like why did you orchestrate this entire
situation Harley Quinn's answer isn't
about love Gotham City was going to hell
in a handbasket you guys didn't care
about what happened like all you cared
about was finding the Joker and all the
Joker cared about was was you chasing
him is the only thing that ever mattered
to you guys all the villains who were
there the penguin and two-face and the
Riddler and poison ivy all these
villains that you happen to face off
against they were just filler
until then next Alexis garbage with the
Joker it's what you lived for but
because of the fact that you gave so
little disregard to what was going on
here no one really looked at the bigger
picture no one ever had a reason to and
so because that Harley Quinn's like you
guys were killing the city on a
multitude of levels somebody had to step
in and somebody had to basically take
the two of you and force you to find a
middle ground
and look at the bigger picture and so
again when the question is asked would
you do it again Hartley's answers
absolutely of course I would do it again
there was never a time when I wouldn't
do it again it's made Gotham City a
better place it's made Gotham City
inherently better and so what is up
happening here is you basically have
Bruce wayne/batman approaching Jim
Gordon and this is so cool because what
he does is he extends an olive branch
the idea of there being a barrier
between like Batman to bat family and
like the Gotham police department that's
being removed
Batman basically gives them the keys of
the Batmobiles lets us have at them I
should have shared my technology with
you a long time ago I should have told
you guys what I was capable of I should
have given you guys the resources to
protect Gotham City and that makes sense
to me it makes sense that it's one thing
for Batman to be a one-man army it's
another for him to give people the
ability to protect themselves and so
because of that when he passes this
whole thing down at the end of the day
there's still the barrier of well why
should we trust you and it's cool
because what Batman says is like I
always wear a mask but I don't know why
I don't know if I wear the mask because
I secure myself I don't know if I wear
the mask because it's designed to scare
people and and this is what's so cool
about this is you could make an argument
for this on the surface looking at
Batman his crusade is rooted in the fact
that his parents died he doesn't want
anybody in Gotham to experience the same
thing but that motivation only runs so
deep it's Shawn Murphy's ability to kind
of add in this added explanation of why
Bruce Wayne's been going on for so long
when he says I just enjoy hurting
criminals the darker part of me actually
wants to kill people I want to kill the
Joker I want to kill two-face like I
want to I want to get rid of these guys
but the part of me that recognizes that
I would cross a line that I can't come
back from doesn't want me to and so it
was kind of like this the idea that
everyone even Batman himself has a Jack
Napier and a Joker and so what is it
happening as he says I've come to this
realization that the only way you guys
are ever going to trust me is to know
that I am a man and so what he does is
he says I'm going to reveal my identity
to you right now which is Bruce Wayne
and then I'm gonna go out publicly and
I'm gonna reveal my identity as Bruce
Wayne to the rest of Gotham City but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain it make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah one heck of a ride I love
that and the white knives is amazing
story but uh yeah guys I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]